SEAN ROBINSON: Some
of the students
in junior lab come in with
some experience on how
to use the equipment, basic
equipment like oscilloscopes,
voltmeters, function
generators, things like that.
Some of them have never
seen those things before.
So there's a learning curve.
In fact, there's
many learning curves.
There's a multi-dimensional
learning surface.
Now all of these skills, no
one of them is very difficult.
But having to learn many
of them simultaneously is
one of the challenges we hear
from students consistently
that they have to
have to get through.
So again, we spend
about the first month
of the course with a lot of
really directed small tasks
just to get people
over the hump in these
you know many small
but multiple tasks
that they all need to learn.